[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Hi, everyone.
This is our overview session.
So if you're totally new
to all this, hopefully,
it'll pique your interest.
Well, Actions on Google
is the developer platform
for the Google Assistant.
Now, users are already
coming to the Assistant
to perform over 1
million actions.
And they're performing
these actions
across a huge range of
devices and context,
from voice-enabled speakers
like the Google Home
to phones to Android Auto to
TVs, Chromebooks, and more,
bringing the number of devices
where you can reach users
to over 500 million.
Actions are now available
in 25-plus locales,
with more coming this year.
It still takes some work and
technical know-how to get up
and running.
And that's why we provide
templates to get you started.
No programming
knowledge required.
You can create fun and
engaging conversational actions
like Personality Quiz,
Trivia, and Flash Cards.
All you have to do is
come to the Actions
console and follow a
step-by-step wizard
to get started
with the template.
Then, you just fill out a
Google Sheets spreadsheet
with the content.
Of course, I know most of you
are developers, so that's never
going to be satisfying enough.
SPEAKER 2: Google
is going to give me
this amazing tool for natural
language understanding called
Dialogflow.
It turns that unstructured
natural language input
into a structured representation
that my endpoint can consume.
Dialogflow sits in the
middle between the Assistant
and my server.
And it does that for
me with hybrid machine
learning powered intent
matching and entity recognition.
All right.
So the way Dialogflow
intents work
is that you train them to listen
for phrases that the user is
going to speak in
each turn of dialogue.
And then each semantically
similar set of phrases
is called an intent, right?
So with the power
of machine learning,
when the user says anything
similar to the phrases you've
provided at any point
in the conversation,
Dialogflow is going
to match that intent.
And how am I going to
account for the variation
in the way each programming
language is spoken?
Programming languages
have nicknames.
Well, Dialogflow offers the
feature of designating synonyms
for each canonical value.
But now the user
is going to respond
with a request to know about
some specific language.
Like, let's say they say,
tell me about Kotlin.
And this time, the
Google Assistant
is going to hand off
directly to my action
because the user's already
entered the dialog.
And it's going to handle the
speech-to-text transcription.
And Dialogflow is
going to match the
which language intent
that I described earlier.
But this time,
instead of responding,
it's going to reach out
to my Webhook hosted
on Cloud Functions for Firebase.
And it's going to
dynamically pull
information about that language
and present it to the user.
And we're also announcing
something really cool
that you've asked
for for a long time.
You can create alpha and
beta versions of your actions
that can be shared with a
limited audience for feedback
and iteration.
SPEAKER 3: Let's talk about
how built-in intents can also
help you get discovered.
So as you can see here,
there are a ton of languages,
there are dialects, there
are cultural differences,
there's slang, that all make
a million different ways
to say the exact same thing.
Built-in intents can provide
a common taxonomy for actions
across all of our
Google surfaces.
So in this scenario,
for example, you'll
see if somebody
says, hey Google, I
want to start
meditating, we can then
suggest just a few
different actions
that we know will
service that need
and are actually
indeed meditation apps.
So here are some of the
built-in intents that we're
working on this year.
You'll see the ones that
are starred will be soon
in developer preview.
So the last tool that I'll
talk about today for discovery
is called Action Links,
which is an awesome tool
to help you promote
your experience.
You'll see it here in
the Headspace example
that we, Google, will actually
promote these experiences
in our own Assistant Directory,
where a user can actually
deep link directly from the
app directory into your action
on the device of their choice.
Assistant Links is really,
really easy to implement.
You can simply generate a
URL really quickly and then
share across all
of your channels.
We will soon open up the
ability for app developers
to sell digital goods
on the Assistant.
This will work across both
phone and voice surfaces.
And we're thinking of
three key use cases
here as we launch this--
in-app digital goods,
subscription services,
and lastly, digital
media purchases.
So what we know here is that
people are creatures of habit.
So we've identified
some of these clusters
and where the Assistant can
actually provide extra value.
This new feature, Routines, lets
users combine multiple actions
into a single command.
So daily updates are
when Google can actually
share a notification and pull
an update at a specified time
each day by the user.
One example of this is you
could get transportation or news
alerts every single
morning at the same time
if Google understands
that about you.
Push notifications are
really exciting because they
could help you do
things in real time.
So things like getting stock
alerts from your favorite news
publisher.
The value to users is
that it actually-- it
helps give you access to
relevant information, which
is immediate, it's content-rich,
and it's specific to you.
What's really valuable to
brands and to some of you folks
here as developers is
that this can really
help you enhance your
utility as a partner to some
of your users.
So thank you, everyone,
so much for having us.
Enjoy the rest of your week.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]